the noke boys are one of the most viral
groups on the internet and they're
dropping an nft that's right i think
that the noke boys are about to have the
biggest nft drop of all time what the
hell am i talking about the milk boys
are dropping something called metacarts
a brand new nft project and this is
going to be the home base the
headquarters the center of their
universe moving forward these guys
announced it a couple of days ago and
they already have 300 000 people in
their discord channel the nft hasn't
even dropped yet but 300 000 people that
consume all their content online sitting
there waiting engaging learning about it
ready to rock and roll now this
shouldn't be surprising that they can
get big numbers the notebooks are
massive across multiple platforms on the
internet if you go ahead and you look at
their youtube or their twitter accounts
they have a ton of reach they have over
seven million youtube subscribers on the
nokboys youtube channel the full send
podcast has over 1.1 million the nft
discord were 300 000 members and they
got about 500 000 followers on twitter
this doesn't even include their own
personal accounts where they have
millions more followers and fans now
what the hell do you get if you go ahead
and you purchase one of these metacard
nfts well first you get a mint pass that
mint pass is going to hold and give all
of the holders first access to tons of
different nft projects they're going to
drop including a happy dad project and
also tons of collabs with other cool nft
projects they're going to hold events
some of them in person some of them in
the virtual world but exclusive full
send events you got a meta card you get
in the event then of course they got
physical locations they're going to come
out with lounges and tons of other types
of physical locations you got a meta
card you're in the physical locations
and then last but not least merch
holders will have that exclusive access
to full send merch that is not available
to non-holders ultimately the milk boys
are pulling the card they're saying if
you ride with us you hold a medic card
if you hold a medic card we're going to
treat you special you're going to get
access to events you're going to get
access to merchandise and ultimately you
are going to get closer to one of the
most viral groups on the internet my
prediction is that the milk boys are
about to drop the hottest nft of 2022
this could possibly become the largest
nft drop we've ever seen i don't know
exactly what's going to happen i don't
know how much money the milk boys are
about to make but what i do know is they
got a large engaged audience they're
locked in and when this nft drops the
internet may break